WE WERE WE SHALL START.
WITH THE SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS I THANK THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH AN EARLY QUORUM GET
OUR BUSINESS DONE QUICKLY.
SO WELCOME TO THE FIRST MEETING
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT THE FIRE
MIDDLE SAFETY TOXIC MATERIALS E.
S. T. M. COMMITTEE.
UP FIRST I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
AMY DEL SEND THE PLEASE STAND.
AMY IS. HARVARD P. H. D..
ARE ALSO IN THE AYE PHYSICAL
CHEMISTRY.
NO PHYSICS AND CHEMISTRY
PHYSICAL CHEMISTS CHEMICAL
PHYSICS.
AS WELL AS HAVING A DEGREE R.
FROM THE KENNEDY SCHOOL IN
GOVERNMENT.
SO A.
SHE WILL HAVE A BRIGHT FUTURE
AND SHE IS STARTING HERE AS
OURS.
OUR SCIENCE FELLOW WHICH I'M
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE A ME ON
BOARD.
THANK YOU AMY.
TODAY WILL BE HEARING TO YEAR
BILLS.
WE HAVE ONE ONLY ONE BELL ON
THE AGENDA AB FOURTEEN NINETEEN.
TO BELL THAT I AM AUTHORIZED I
AM AUTHOR ON. PESTICIDE USE
ENFORCEMENT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO ESTABLISH QUORUM.
QUIRK.
PRESIDENT QUIRK IS PRESENT CHEN.
CAN IS HERE.
BUT AYE-MOORLACH.
AND.
WROTE BIRD WAS HERE.
YOU SEE THAT UPSET.
HOLDEN.
MURATSUCHI WE HAVE ACQUIRED.
ALRIGHT SHOWS I AM PRESENTING.
I'D LIKE TO ASK A VICE CHAIR.
CHAN TO COME OVER.
AND CITY AREAS AS CHAIR. WELL I
PRESENT
.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AMBULANCE.
IF YOU DR.
RICHARD REPORTER.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR.
AND THEN THANK YOU MEMBERS.
.
PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS A
RECOMMENDS TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT I SHALL TAKE TIME ACCEPTING
ADDITIONALLY.
I'M ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS THAT
PROVIDE MORE DIRECTION REGARDING
WHAT THE. DIRECTOR CAN TAKE OVER
A CASE I'M ACCEPTING BOTH ITS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
THOSE AMENDMENTS ABOUT WHEN THE
DIRECTOR WOULD TO A TAKEOVER
CASE ARE.
A DIRECT RESULT OF CONCERNS THAT
THE FARM BUREAU AND OTHER
FARMING INTERESTS HAD.
WE ARE STILL WORKING ON THE
FINAL.
WE'VE GOT SOME LANGUAGE IN THERE
STATE WERE STILL WORKING TO
FINALIZE IT BUT THIS IS A GOOD
START AND THEY'VE GIVEN US SOME
ALTERNATIVE LANGUAGE. WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
AB FOURTEEN NINETEEN WILL
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION AUTHORITY.
MORE AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE THE
STATE'S A PESTICIDE USE LAW FOR
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS.
RECENTLY THERE BEEN A LARGE
NUMBER OF SERIOUS CASES OF
PESTICIDE DRIFT.
IT IF NEGATIVE NEGATIVELY IF
IMPACTED YOU MINUTE WILDLIFE
HEALTH.
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL VIOLATIONS
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULTY A TO
ENFORCE BECAUSE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS.
HAVE LIMITED THORNY TO SITE FOR
OR VIOLATIONS THAT EXTEND
OUTSIDE THEIR BOUNDARIES.
FURTHER ADDING TO THE DIFFICULTY
OF ENFORCEMENT IS SET THE
MAXIMUM PENALTY THE CAN BE LEVEL
FOR VIOLATIONS.
HAS NOT INCREASED IN FIFTEEN
YEARS.
UP MY BILL STRENGTH THE SIDES
ARE PESTICIDE USE LAWS IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS.
FIRST IT GIVES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AGAINST
SERIOUS CASES ANOTHER WORDS WHEN
THEY'RE.
R. HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
ARE WHEN THEY'RE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS.
POLLUTING THEIR DRINKING WATER
SOURCE WHEN THERE'S SOMETHING
VERY SERIOUS.
A SECOND THE APARTMENT INSTEAD
OF HAVING THE ABILITY TO LEVEL A
FINE OF FIVE THOUSAND IS RAISED
TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
A THIRD IT ALLOWS SPEAK
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS TO REFER CASES
SUCH AS WHEN THERE'S A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST TO THE DEPARTMENT.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE
TWO MEMBERS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION.
KIM'S CHAIR.
BUT MY NAME IS THERESA MARKS AND
I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT PESTICIDE
REGULATION.
WE ARE SEEKING PASSAGE OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETEEN BECAUSE IT
WOULD GIVE A STATE GREATER
TOOLS.
TWO UP PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT BY ALLOWING DPR
TO LET THE CIVIL PENALTIES AND
SOME OF THE MORE EGREGIOUS
CASES.
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT'S
MISSION IS TO PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT BY
REGULATING PESTICIDES SALES IN
USE IN FOSTERING REDUCED RISK
PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
THE STATE HAS A VERY ROBUST
REGULATORY PROGRAM AND WE WORK
WITH OUR COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS TO ENSURE THAT
PESTICIDE APPLICATORS ARE
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS AND
PESTICIDES ARE LEGALLY APPLIED.
WHILE MOST PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW THERE ARE STILL
SOME APPLICATIONS THAT RESULT IN
VIOLATION AND AND A PORTION OF
THOSE THAT CAUSE HUMAN HEALTH
CONCERNS ARE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE. AND THOSE
ARE THE CASES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY THESE INCIDENTS
TRIGGER PRIORITY INVESTIGATION
IN THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER CONCURRENTLY LEVY A
MAXIMUM FINE OF FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION.
DP R. BELIEVES THAT SOME
PRIORITY INVESTIGATION CASES
WARRANT HIGHER PENALTY AMOUNT.
OF COURSE THERE ARE ALSO
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE
COUNTY AYE COMMISSIONERS TO TAKE
AN ACTION. OF THOSE WOULD BE
THINGS IF YOU HAVE A MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS MULTIPLE COUNTY
JURISDICTIONS ARE THERE'S A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST. AYE NDP R.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
THE CICS WINDOW SITUATIONS ARISE
ALSO.
WE'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS A WE ARE WORKING
WITH HIM ON MAKING SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE.
IS IS SOMETHING THAT I FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH WE
CONSIDER THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS ARE PARTNERS.
I IN OUR IN MEETING OUR GOALS
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
WE ARE WORKING IN HARMONY WITH
THEM OUT WITH THIS NEW
REGULATION ARE WITH THIS NEW LAW
SKIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
JUST HERE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
I AM BILL I'LL YOU KNOW FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
ALSO.
SAME SUPPORT FROM BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS AND PISSED
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK THANK
YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ANY OTHER
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ADAM AND
COTTON FROM CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK TODAY.
AND WE ARE ALSO VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE EFFECTIVE INVESTIGATIONS
ARE. TIMELY.
AND THAT RIG RESULT IN STIFF
FINES WHEN THERE ARE SERIOUS ON.
SERIOUS PROP UP. WHEN THERE IS A
HUMAN ILLNESS HER SERIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS AND WE
THINK THIS BILL IS A. GOOD STEP
TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
INVESTIGATING YOU THINK.
MR TURN MEMBERS NOT USE I REALLY
GOING TO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER SINCE
YOU'RE DISSOCIATION.
I LISTENED CAREFULLY TO THAT
TESTIMONY FROM DP ON THE AUTHOR
REFLECTS
EVERYTHING WE UNDERSTAND ABOUT
THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD. I WE
CAN WORKING WITH THEM SINCE LAST
YEAR AND A LITTLE MORE TENSE IN
THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE AS TO HOW THIS PROCESS WILL
WORK. WE HAD A A QUICK LOOK AT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO US LAST NIGHT. I'D
FEEL IF YOU TAKE A HUGE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION OUR
DISTRIBUTING THOSE THROUGHOUT
OUR ASSOCIATION WHILE THAT
POSITION ON THAT SHORTLY.
HOPEFULLY I HAVE A LIEU MENDOZA
WITH ME WHO IS A AND I
COMMISSIONER FROM YOU COUNTY.
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION AS
WELL FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THIS PROCESS WORKS
THINKING.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION FOR YOUR
SUPPORT YEAH. DANICA OFTEN ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
THINK YOU.
THE WORK HAVE TO CLEAR IT CHAIR.
.
JUST ONE FACTOR THAT WE HAVE TWO
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION SO.
AND NOW FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YEAH COME ON UP.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CYNTHIA CORY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU.
I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS A
QUIRKS WORKING WITH US ON ON THE
ON THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WHICH
WE ALSO SAW FOR THE FIRST TIME
LAST NIGHT. THEY WERE THEY WE
HAD SUGGESTED SOME LANGUAGE AND
AS MATT SAID EARLIER WITH THE AG
COMMISSIONERS WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY TOWARDS GETTING THERE. ON
OUR CONCERN WAS NOT THAT BE THEY
WANTED REINSERT THIS LANGUAGE
WHICH WAS AT FORMALLY IN STATUTE
IT WAS OF THE COSTA BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND.
BUT THAT THE WAY IT WAS WRITTEN
WAS GONNA GIVE A.
IT WAS GONNA EXCERPTED THE
AUTHORITY OF THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS THE WAY IT WAS
WRITTEN SO WE HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT WE ASK THAT THAT BE
CLARIFIED. SO THE LANGUAGE THAT
WE WERE GIVEN LAST NIGHT I JUST
THINK IN AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN AND I THINK WOMEN TALKED
ABOUT IT WITH THE PAIR BUT WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT IT WITH
THIS SIMPLY MEMBER. ON I JUST
THINK THAT HE'S BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLARIFICATION AGAIN THAT
IT'S THE COUNTY THAT MAKES A
DETERMINATION IF THEY'VE GOT A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST OR IF THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO HANDLE IT. WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COUNTY HAS THE FIRST CHOICE
BECAUSE THAT THERE THAT THERE
THE REGULATORS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL NAY SHOULD MAINTAIN THAT
UNTIL THEY THEY ASK. FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM.
FROM THE FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND
THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THAT IN
IN ENFORCEMENT POLICY WHICH I
ALSO SHARED WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK. ON WITH THE SECOND THING
THAT WE ALSO ASK FOR WE GOT
CONCERNED ABOUT GOING FROM FIVE
TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND ONE
JUMP.
.
FARM BUREAU SUPPORTED THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HANNAH BETH
JACKSON SPILL WE WERE THE ONLY
MAINSTREAM AT GROUP THAT DID AND
I WORK CLOSELY WITH HANNAH BETH
ON THAT.
AND WE WENT FROM THERE FROM ONE
TO FIVE THOUSAND AND.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE WE
VAST DPR LIKE OKAY WOULD SHOW US
THE MONEY WAIT WAIT WHERE'S THAT
VIOLATIONS THAT THAT WOULD SAY
WE NEED GO FROM FIVE TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND.
PROVIDE ELATION
YOU'VE GOT THE AUTHORITY A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PLACES IF YOU'RE
ALREADY DOING ANYTHING TO HURT
HEALTH OR THE ENVIRONMENT TO TO
GO THAT FAR.
SO WE'VE JUST ASKED THAT THAT BE
TALKED ABOUT AND MAYBE THAT WE
CONSIDER CERTAIN SOMETHING MORE
OF A MIDDLE GROUND WE SUGGEST A
TEN THOUSAND.
SO THOSE ARE THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE SO AT THIS POINT WE CAN'T.
SUPPORT THE BILL WE'VE GOT YOU
SAY WERE IN CONCERN AND WE'RE
HOPING TO GET TO WHERE WE CAN
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE OF THE COMMISSION BORN
KNOWING TEACHER COME BEHALF OF
WESTERN PLANT HEALTH ASSOCIATION
WERE IN THE SAME POSITION AS.
FARM BUREAU JUST STATED
CONCERNED.
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
REALLY APPRECIATE.
WHAT HE'S DONE SO FAR AND
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE COUNTY?
MAINTAINS THAT AUTHORITY.
SO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR BUT AT THIS POINT
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE HOME OVER THE
QUESTIONS FOR IDEA CAMINO
NERVES.
ANY QUESTIONS.
CONSUMERS USUALLY THANK YOU.
SO I'M READING THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE.
ARE ON THE ISSUE OF THE PENALTY
IT'S IT'S NOT MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND I CORRECT THAT'S
GREAT OKAY SO IT Vl BE LESS.
AND.
.
I WOULD LEAVE IT UP TO THE.
DEPARTMENT TO TALK ABOUT YEAH
WHEN IT WOULD BE MORE LESS OKAY
AND IN TERMS OF FOR.
THE DEPARTMENTS. DISCRETION AND.
ARMED INVESTIGATING AND AND.
LOVING.
.
I I I I BELIEVE THEIR THEIR IS
A A PROCESS FOR APPEAL. A IN IN
TERMS OF.
.
NOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT INTO
THAT OKAY.
I GUESS FOR THERE IS A PROCESS
FOR APPEAL AND AS FAR AS THE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GOES THE.
THAT.
THE CASES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OF SOME OF THOSE MOST
EGREGIOUS CASES.
THERE MAYBE SITUATION WHERE YOU
MIGHT ONLY HAVE A ONE PERSON
INVOLVED BUT WAS THERE WAS A
SERIOUS ILLNESS CAUSED. OR THERE
COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL HARM THAT WOULD
WARRANT THAT. UP BUT AGAIN THAT
THERE IS A.
THERE'S THAT POSITION WHERE
IT'S UP TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
SO IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THAT WOULD BE IT WHAT WE
WOULD SEEK IN EVERY CASE.
YEAH I AS FAR AS THE PROCEDURAL
ASPECT GOES. RIGHT NOW.
WHEN THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS A
* PENALTY THEN THERE'S A
HEARING PERSON REQUEST A HEARING
AND THEN AFTER THAT HEARING THAT
CAN ALSO REQUEST AN APPEAL TO
THE DIRECTOR'S OFFICE. IT WOULD
BE A SIMILAR SITUATION THE
PERSONAL IF WE BROUGHT THAT THE
VIOLATION THE PERSON COULD
REQUEST A HEARING WE HAVE OUR
OWN ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
OFFICER IN COURSE WE COULD USE
PROBABLY THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICER
TO YOU WE WOULD HAVE A HEARING.
AND THE APPEAL FROM THERE WE GO
DIRECTLY TO THE COURTS. AND AND
SO YOU SAY THAT TO THIS SHOULD
BE.
OF THIS PROCESS BE GAUGED ONLY
THE MOST EGREGIOUS OF CASES THAT
HOW WOULD.
LED THE RESPONDENT CHALLENGE
WHETHER THIS IS EGREGIOUS OR
NOT.
WELL I MEAN I THINK THAT THE
WHITE PROBABLY THEY ALWAYS WOULD
WE I'M WHEN I SAY IT THAT
CERTAINLY THE MOST EGREGIOUS
CASES BUT ALSO THOSE OTHER CASES
WHERE THERE COULD BE A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST FOR THAT KIND OF
STUFF BUT. THE EGREGIOUS CASES
WE LOOK AT ARE THOSE WHERE
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT HARM.
IT WHERE THERE ARE THOSE WHERE
THERE'S BEEN A SITUATION WHERE
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS DOES NOT.
IS NOT WARRANTED THERE THERE'S
JUST OUT THERE IS ACTION TO THE
POINT WHERE WOODS WORN A MORE
SIGNIFICANT PENALTY. I GUESS
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS THE DUE
PROCESS IN TERMS OF THE
RESPONDENTS ABILITY TO. TO.
YOU KNOW NOT JUST RELY ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S DETERMINATION OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES EGREGIOUS BUT.
YOU KNOW WILL WHAT KIND OF A DUE
PROCESS IS THERE IN TERMS OF
RESPOND.
EQUIP US ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
DPR.
IN TERMS OF THIS BILL WE
ACTUALLY OUT A CRITERIA WHICH WE
IDENTIFIES THE PARTY INVEST
INVESTIGATION CRITERIA. THAT IS
LAID OUT THROUGH A MEMORANDUM
UNDERSTANDING WITH US USEPA AND.
THE COUNTY AG COMMISSIONERS AND
SECRETARY DOES LAYOUTS.
WHAT'S THE THRESHOLDS IN WHICH
SOMETHING COULD BE CONSIDERED A
PRIORITY INVESTIGATION OF THOSE
WOULD BE CASES WHERE.
HUMAN HEALTH WAS INVOLVED
LARGE ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE
THINGS LIKE THAT AND IT THIS
LAYOUT THAT CREEK AREA OKAY.
AND AND LAST QUESTION IS.
THE PENALTIES FOR EACH
VIOLATION.
IN IN THE CASE OF LIKE SAY.
ARE A.
BETH SIGHED INCIDENT THEN THAT
EXTENDS OVER.
SEVERAL DAYS.
.
THIS ACT.
IT IS AT AND HOW IS EACH.
INCIDENT DEFINED.
THAT THE.
THE INCIDENT WOULD BE.
.
WOULD BE. THE WAY IT WOULD BE.
UPGRADING TO MORE THAN ONE
WOULD BE IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN
ONE PERSON WAS INJURED OKAY.
SO IN.
IF ANY OF IN A BID TO IT
TYPICALLY WHEN YOU HAVE A
PESTICIDE ILLNESS IT'S USUALLY
AT AN ACUTE PASS I KNOW THIS
WORD IT'S AN OCCASION HAPPENS.
IT WITHIN ONE DAY OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SO.
BUT IT HELPS BUT IF THERE'S BUT
THE THE NUMBER OF INCIDENTS TO
BE CHARGED. FOR PENALTY TO BE
CHARGED DEPENDS ON THE NUMBER OF
VICTIMS.
YEAH WE WOULD HAVE THAT ABILITY
TO AT EACH
I TO SS EVERY.
INDIVIDUAL PERSON AS A SEPARATE
VIOLATION.
I THINK.
THANK YOU.
GARCIA.
I THINK YOU'RE DO YOU WANT TO
MOVE THE BILL.
AND.
I WANT TO THANK MR QUIRKS WORK
TO GET THE AMENDMENTS AND ALL
AND WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION.
.
ON THIS.
REALLY QUICKLY ON THE.
HOW WE LANDED ON THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR AMOUNTS IS MY
QUESTION AND THEN BE? THERE'S NO
INDEX FOR THIS TO BE ADJUSTED
AUTOMATICALLY IN THE FUTURE AT
ANY POINT BUT SAY.
THIS IS LAST I THINK IN THE
SEVENTIES OF THE LEFT HAND OF
NUMBER WITH THE JUST THAT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE TO COME BACK
THAT WAY AND HAS SAID HAVE LEAF
CONSIDER SOME SORT OF FOR INDEX
OCHOA.
ON THIS FINE.
AND I WOULD ARGUE WITH YOUR
DEPARTMENT THAT.
WE BASICALLY DID THIS KIND OF
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME WAY IT WAS
DONE IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE WE
WENT FROM WE GET A FIVE FOLD
INCREASE.
ON THE FINE IT WENT FROM ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS SUDDENLY GET
THIS FIVE FOLD INCREASE IN WE DO
FEEL LIKE THAT IT'S NECESSARY.
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
DETERRENT EFFECT.
ON THESE PARTICULARLY EGREGIOUS
AYE ISSUES UP WE HAVE NOT
CONSIDERED THAT WE'VE NOT EVEN
DISCUSSED AMONG OURSELVES I
THINK ANY TYPE OF OF.
PERIODIC. REVIEW.
AND WE COULD CERTAINLY AS WE
TALK WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD DISCUSS.
I AM NOT COMMITTING INTO
ANYTHING EVELYN CURIOUS JUST
BECAUSE I KEEP.
DO THE JAPANESE HEAPS INFLOWS
COMING BACK TO ADJUST AND IN THE
HIGH MINUTES JUST TO THAT SINCE
THE SEVENTIES OR. WHATEVER THAT
MAY BE AND SO I JUST YOU KNOW
WONDER IF.
IF WE NEED TO KEEP REVISITING OF
THIS A PLAN THAT WE JUST AT. AN
INDEX BUT I'M NOT COMMITTING YOU
TWENTY THING NOW THINKING AND
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
CAN DISCUSS.
BUT ONE OF THE FIRST START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD HAVING WORKED IN
ANY ARE IN A FORM WORKING
COMMUNITY I SAW MORE THAN MY
FAIR SHARE OF PESTICIDE
EXPOSURES. FROM.
AND YET I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL AND WANTED TO
SHARE A FEW OF THEM IF I COULD.
HER FIRST MIGHT CONCERN USUALLY
STEMS FROM TAKING AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL.
AND REALLY WANTED TO DO A LOT A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE AG
COMMISSIONERS AND THEIR ROLE AND
PARTNERSHIP.
IN THIS.
WE MADE AN ATTEMPT TO CALL MY
FRESNO AG COMMISSIONER LESS
RIGHTS TO ASK HIS OPINION OF THE
BILL AND HE WAS NOT. WILLING YET
TO GET TO A PLACE OF SUPPORT.
TO EARN MY SUPPORT I LIKE MY
LOCALS TELLING ME.
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WANT AND NEED A TOOL THAT WOULD
HELP THEM IN SO. I'M TRYING TO
ASK FROM YOU DO YOU ANTICIPATE
AT SOME POINT THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF THIS TO OFFICIALLY
GET THE AG COMMISSIONERS IN
SUPPORT.
.
THAT'S THE QUESTION UP BUT THE
STATEMENT I NEED TO MAKE IS
TODAY I AM MOST LIKELY NOT GOING
TO VOTE ON THIS ISSUE BEFORE US.
MOSTLY BECAUSE OF.
THE FINE ITSELF.
NOW WHILE I HEAR THE FIVE FOLD
INCREASE I THANK YOU CAN ALWAYS
PLAY WITH NUMBERS YOU CAN ALSO
SAY THAT GOING FROM ONE THOUSAND
FIVE THOUSAND WAS A FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLAR INCREASE.
SO WHY WE INCREASING ANOTHER
FOUR THOUSAND TO GET US CLOSER
TO THE TEN THOUSAND NUMBER THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
SO AYE WANT. ASK AND I'M HOPING
THAT EVENTUALLY WE CAN GET THE
AG COMMISSIONERS ON BOARD AS A
WAY FOR THOSE OF US WHO. ARE
STRADDLING THE FENCE NOW TO SEE
IF WE COULD SUPPORT THE BILL.
BUT AND HOPING THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE FORWARD
WE FIND A WAY WITH THAT FINE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR LOCAL
CONTROL IS STILL THERE.
YEAH. SHOW IN RESPONSE TO THAT
AND AT FIRST OF ALL YOUR COUNTY
COMMISSION WOULD OF SEEN THE
LATEST AMENDMENT SO. UP PRIOR TO
THE LATEST AMENDMENT IF SOME IT
SAID THAT THE.
ARM.
APARTMENT COULD TAKE OVER
CERTAIN CASES BUT DIDN'T
SPECIFY.
R. UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS THAT
WAS WHAT WAS PUT IN HERE.
WHAT THE OPPOSITION CONCERNED
ABOUT ON THAT AMENDMENT WAS JUST
MAKING IT MORE CLEAR WHO
DETERMINES WHEN THERE'S A
VIOLATION?
I CHOOSE ME WHEN THERE'S A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AND WHO
DETERMINES IF THE DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T HAVE ADEQUATE.
.
OUR RESOURCES AND ARE MAKING
THAT CLEAR DOES THE DEPARTMENT
TO HAVE A POSITION THAT THEY.
HAVE YOU JUST. THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS YET.
HOW THEY CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE?
WE ARE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS BUT I THINK WE CAN
CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE TO THEIR.
THEIR UP.
AGREEMENT
I WEEK BELIEVING WE HAVE NO
DESIRE TO USURP THEIR AUTHORITY
OR TO TAKE WE ANY CASES AWAY
FROM THEM PARTICULARLY WHAT WE
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS TO. PUT
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THEM IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH THE GUYS.
AND I'M HAPPY IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK WITH THEIR.
REPRESENTATIVE BEGAN.
YEAH SURE PLEASE. PLEASE COME
UP.
THANK YOU SO A NUMBER.
AS STATED LET'S HASN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE FROM.
FROM LAST NIGHT I DID SEND IT
TO HIM AND EVERYONE ELSE IN
ASSOCIATION AND WAITING ON A
RESPONSE WHAT FROM THAT.
.
AS FAR AS AS DP OUR AND AND THE.
TO CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
THEM GOING FORWARD IT'S.
IT'S VERY CLEAR TO US THAT THEY
VIEW THIS AS A TOOL.
IT COUNTIES CAN USE AND
INSTANCES WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
WERE STILL TRYING TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE ON ON WHAT THAT MEANS YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S.
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST WHETHER
IT'S A LACK OF RESOURCES.
AND OR IF IT'S JUST A CASE
WHERE THE COUNTY FEELS
OVERWHELMED THEM WANTS WANTS TO
CALL UPON DPR FOR EXTRA
ASSISTANCE NOT EXTRA HAMMER THAT
THEY CAN PROVIDE.
SO. IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THE OPPOSITION STATES THAT THERE
WERE FOUR CASES AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND ONE CASE AND TWENTY
SEVENTY.
IS THIS BILL MEANT TO FIX THE
ONE CASE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND. IS THAT THE RIGHT WAY FOR
US TO BE LEGISLATING.
SO THE THE YEARS OF.
.
I THINK TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN THAT WERE MENTIONED
AYE I LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT. WE
HAVE A STATUE OF LIMITATIONS OF
TWO YEARS AND THE FOR THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY STILL ONGOING
IMPENDING. THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A
LOWER NUMBER OF THAT A MORE
ACCURATE NUMBER MAYBE FROM
TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY FOURTEEN
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY SIX.
CASES
SO THE REASON WHY THERE'S A LOW
NUMBER ON THE OTHER ONES IS
THOSE THOSE INVESTIGATIONS ARE
STILL PENDING.
THANK YOU MISTER JUSTICE A
STATEMENT OF.
SHE CHAIR I'VE WANT TO. ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA THANK YOU FOR WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION APPRECIATE YOU
DOING THAT AND SOUNDS LIKE YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK ON. A SOME
LANGUAGE WITH THEM AND AS
SOMEONE A RAMBLE I WON'T BE
VOTING TODAY. BUT I HOPE ARE YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK IN THAT I CAN
SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR.
GREAT.
NONE.
NINE SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN NINETEEN. THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK.
BY.
QUIRK AYE.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE.
ARAMBULA.
PEROT.
CHRISTINA GARCIA. PRESENTED OF
CI.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
MURATSUCHI AYE WHAT IT.
FIVE.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
RIGHT FIGURES CHAIR THANK YOU
ALL FOR GREAT DISCUSSION AND
GOOD QUESTIONS
.
YEAH
THE. MEETING IS OVER THANK YOU